As our builds become increasingly more
complex, we want to ensure that we don't
redo any work that has already been done
the last time we executed our build.
This is especially important
during development,
when we run our builds often many times
a day with just some minor changes.
It would be a huge impediment
to the development process
if our build had to start
from scratch every time.
We call the idea of only doing
the minimum amount of work necessary
incremental builds.
For example,
let's consider an Android application.
Building our app requires compiling
our code, generating source files, and
packaging static resources
into the final APK.
If we were to say,
change one of our layout files,
we don't want to have to
compile our code again.
That would be unnecessary.
Gradle accomplishes this by tracking
each task's inputs and outputs.
Before each task is run, Gradle saves a
snapshot of the inputs used by the task.
If that particular task doesn't have
any snap shots of its input yet, or
if the inputs have changed,
then Gradle will run the task again.
Gradle additionally saves a snapshot
of the outputs created by this task.
The next time Gradle goes
to run the same task,
it compares the inputs to
the snap shot it saved earlier.
If the inputs match,
Gradle then also checks the outputs.
If the outputs haven't been messed
with since the last time the task ran,
then the task can be skipped.
If the outputs have changed or are
missing, then the task must run again.
When Gradle determines that
no work needs to be done and
the task can be skipped,
the task is said to be up-to-date.